[Music]
I'm Jeff Glor co-host of CBS this
morning Saturday we are revisiting some
of our stories that have brought us hope
and inspirations from across the world
we begin in Boston Massachusetts where
city and community leaders are engaged
in a bold experiment to use higher
education to transform its dangerous
neighborhoods Boston on cornered
recruits the city's youth involved in
gangs even paying them $400 a week to
drop their guns and enroll in college
Dana Jacobson tells us more
33 year old Antonio Franklin is studying
sociology at Boston's Bunker Hill
Community College how hard has school
been for you the last couple of years
extremely hard juggling school with my
family it's very odd but when you buy
you something if you want it that bad
you're gonna push yourself to get to get
to what you want Bunker Hill is only
seven miles but a world away from the
Dorchester neighborhood where Franklin
grew up he's there on a scholarship of
sorts part of a program that gives
former gang members money to stay in
school some people may look at this and
they'll say this was a guy he wasn't a
gang why should we reward him by paying
him to go to school now I would say that
no we're not being paid really to go to
school
I appreciate the money it keeps us from
detour and off of our pathway gives us a
little bit of help getting in this
program they gave me a second chance the
game yet another opportunity to live my
life Franklin started getting involved
with gangs around the age of 13 what
were some of the things that you got
involved in well you know I got involved
with you know selling drugs I got
involved with Street stuff I got fights
I've been stabbed shot three times
you know I've been to a lot the game
caught up with him in 2007 the cop was
shot you know it was my actions that
caused the reaction he was shot by his
own partner and I ended up getting 9 to
10 years for it but Franklin's life
would change at his sentencing thanks to
what that wounded officer said he wanted
me to going in he wanted me to change
for the better better meant myself and
to hate I coming from a police officer
speci a police
so that was a victim of my actions and
we really was a change of heart he'd
served ten years before his release he
got his GED did you know what would
await you when you got out no that's the
most scariest thing a friend put
Franklin in touch with Francisco de Tina
D Tina is a college readiness adviser
like Franklin he's also a former gang
member from Dorchester my great teacher
told me he said by the time you're 18
you either gonna be dead or in jail I
kind of at that time I kind of believed
it I thought that was my path I just
brushed it off and say oh whatever but
then when you know school wasn't for me
no more and I was hanging out on the
street I was stuck in that corner one
day a recruiter reached out from the
local nonprofit college-bound Dorchester
and asked to Tina to take some classes
what did you think when he said that to
you school is not for me
college-bound Dorchester helped to Tina
get his GED he's paying them back by
helping to recruit others into the
program obviously it isn't the first
time it might not work the second and
might not even work third time the key
to being a recruiter and doing this work
it's not giving up always go back try
again
why don't you give up because someone
didn't give up on me - Tina is now one
of 15 recruiters who college-bound
founder mark colleton considers core
influencers for the organization's
three-year-old program Boston uncor nerd
the strange thing is that I believe it's
gang leaders and only gang leaders that
can actually transform communities why
is that they're so disproportionately
powerful but that power can be harnessed
for good I think the one unconventional
thing that people find is you're going
to pay someone who's in a gang been in a
gang to go to school right it would be
great
if everybody could do exactly the right
thing all the time none of us do that
when you offer them a different
opportunity and you say we will invest
in you to make different choices they're
desperate to do that they want a way out
they just need an excuse in an
opportunity colleton can relate having
made poor choices as a teenager after
his parents divorce I immediately sort
of fell off the cliff started selling
drugs breaking into houses like just
sort of went wild yeah and I would get
arrested and my college-educated white
mother would come down to the police
station and like make the police
apologize to me and send me home
he says the philosophy behind the
program Boston nun cornered is based on
three core principles hire former gang
members there's different scholarships
out there we want to try to get you
insist on high expectations from
students and invest in their future in
other words don't be afraid to put your
money where your mouth is to give these
leaders an opportunity to make positive
choices and if you just do those three
simple things your city will change what
did you think when you first heard about
it I said it's about time Boston Police
Commissioner William grass the first
african-american to lead his force sees
this as an extension of the department's
community policing enacted citywide we
want to reach the individuals that are
having challenges and then help them out
so you actually paying the gang member
or are you paying paying a future right
so you think gangs right we pay for the
lawyers incarceration the upkeep no this
is an investment into someone's future
to change their life for the better
and that'll be a return investment for
us the community like Antonio Franklin
using the investment made in him to lay
a foundation for his future and his
families you have a two-year-old yes
what does this program mean in terms of
him an example you're able to set for
him a role model like it shows that you
know I don't want my son
to look back at my life
google me and see that oh my father was
just somebody who was in the streets I
wanted to see that my father you know he
was in the streets but he came home and
he really did good and I just do good he
did good for the betterment of everybody
around him that's who I want to be after
the break we take you to one of the
world's largest refugee camps in Jordan
see how some are finding ways to heal
from the trauma of being displaced more
than 10 million people have been
displaced by the Syrian civil war that's
been ongoing for nine years as a result
millions of experienced psychological
trauma but Michelle Miller was able to
witness a special program in Jordan
meant to address a crisis in care for
these invisible wounds this is Market
Street here and it's a wrestling
bustling urban center so does absolutely
you can get pretty much anything you
need that you would find that online or
other cities nearby but this isn't your
average city in the Middle East it's a
center of Commerce in one of the world's
largest refugee camps the za tree camp
in Jordan home to nearly 80,000 Syrians
displaced by civil war none of us should
ever be ok with calling this normal but
it's become an accepted reality for a
lot of people Mike
Nick and Chuck has been doing
humanitarian work here since 2012 this
started as a small collection of tents
but has turned into something more
permanent I saw that journey of what
started out as shock of adjusting to
this place of leaving home of losing
friends losing family losing the very
sense of identity that was once sacred
that loss would be difficult for anyone
but perhaps hardest for those with
invisible wounds nuclear weapons
chemical weapons barrel bombs we've
innovated in ways to stress people out
to traumatize people and in the same way
we have to innovate by understanding
science and how we can hack those
systems that we already have to heal
Nick and Chuck isn't just an aid worker
he's also a brain scientist
thank you everyone for coming he works
for beyond conflict a nonprofit that
combines behavioral science and
humanitarian work to do that here NIC
and Chuck created a self-help tool
called the field guide for barefoot
psychologists through this story about
two displaced Syrian siblings the guide
simplifies brain science and teaches
readers coping skills to recover from
trauma so there are emotional mental
processes that have a physical impact on
your body absolutely it can be addressed
absolutely whose simple exercises
something very simple using your breath
putting pressure to certain points and
joints in your body activates different
aspects of the nervous system of the
endocrine system whatever it might be we
believe knowledge is power
let's give knowledge it's not that hard
phenomena and kapha illusion is a Syrian
refugee living year she leads field
guide sessions to teach mindfulness and
to show others that anger and depression
are natural responses to the horrors
they've experienced
I feel more relaxed but I don't feel as
though I've been through the trauma or
stress that you have of course yes of
course
the body will imply to the brain that I
can relax
maybe I frankly feel like me animal or I
can deal with the situation I'm okay and
we will be able to relax I'm just one
along and at the same time we will be
effective these classes have made all
the difference for yes mean on the Sun a
mother of four where did you feel the
anxiety where was it
identify it shuts your throat down
nightmares about the war made her seek
out a psychiatrist at saw tree but she
would give me a medication like sleeping
pills or a sedative I felt like it was
local anesthesia I didn't cook what
after the local anesthesia I go back to
feeling the same way
on the Sun says which she's learned
has driven much of her anxiety away
allowing her to focus on what really
matters
Nana Sonata what I want for myself is to
be a good mother to find my way what I
want for my children is to realize the
dreams I had for myself there's mental
health here available to people how is
your program different anyone is willing
to read a story by using story where
functionally doing group therapy where
you're allowing people who are living in
a culture of incredible stigma against
mental health and affective out where
you're still talking about things by
letting people talk about characters in
a story where they're seeing themselves
perhaps the field guides stories hit
home because they were co-authored by
someone who lived them Muhammad Kier
Mustafa what can you tell me about how
you came here caboose it was a nightmare
she first just going from village to
village then when things got even worse
and the situation became more difficult
there were no options so we had to come
here
Moustafa put his suffering on the page
to improve the lives of his fellow
refugees if a person understood his
surroundings his body his needs if you
understood his responses to
circumstances and traumas then he will
definitely be able to react properly
that certainly would Abdallah casa
Hwanhee hopes for he defected from the
syrian government and now lives in this
sea of shipping containers but he dreams
of raising his sons in a place with more
opportunities the guide came to help to
open up a person's eyes to help him find
the treasure that lies within him the
guide was able to communicate with a
person soul this is how the guide was
really able to help the field guide is
currently the subject of one of the
largest studies to measure well-being in
a post-conflict zone and the findings
are promising there's some people who
because of the nature of their PTSD
they're hyper they can't control their
impulses for other people the response
to loss to trauma has been to chill out
to mellow out too much every individual
no matter their symptom profile seems to
be getting what they need if this works
here where else can it work I want to
see this with young incarcerated men in
the United States I want to see
neo-nazis dealing with their own stress
and trauma I want to see migrants coming
across the border dealing with this no
one is guaranteed a life free from
trauma these are universal experiences
these are human experiences that can and
will affect people at all levels of
society and I want to see this in as
many places as possible across the
United States
coming up we visit the innovation
Cathedral where a 100 year old church in
New Jersey is now home to the world's
largest producer and seller of
audiobooks we'll be right back Newark
New Jersey has seen its share of hard
times but things are looking up in the
Brick City thanks to innovative
public-private partnerships like the one
formed between the city and the
audiobook company audible Michelle
Miller saw how it's helping transform
the lives of the city's residents how
did you find this place
this is just one of the great buildings
in Newark that we've just embraced you
might think the world's largest producer
and seller of audiobooks would be in
Seattle or Silicon Valley it's the right
thing to do and a lot of reasons why but
audible founder Don Katz just expanded
his company into the soul of downtown
Newark are these new no they were
written were original they were from
1932 so the church burned down audibles
new home is this once abandoned 100 year
old church it's gone from house of
worship to workspace this was the
original choir loft where people gather
to brainstorm and create ideas it's
called the innovation cathedral so what
are people doing here so they're
building various technologically
oriented products these are mostly
software development engineers in fact
audible has become Newark's
fastest-growing private employer with a
workforce of more than 1,600 in the city
all engineering a new frontier of
entertainment audible didn't just leave
reading alone and if you think about it
there are millions and millions and
millions of people is inaudible not
because we looked at the concept of
reading and then thought about
refracting it through this artful
performances by actors but it's not just
hack being developed here
it's young minds to as a partner in the
city's education system audible donated
more than 4 million dollars over the
past year by giving Newark public high
school students in Amazon tablet
headphones and an audible subscription I
was a book nerd
book nerd oh definitely I read a lot of
books it also offered students like
Nicole ransom internships and a paycheck
oh yeah you paid I started out with $14
an hour mm-hmm so that that's that's a
lot a pretty good investment of my time
CEO Don Katz got his start as a
journalist but developed into a true
tech innovator he's credited with
creating the first digital audio player
back in 1997 four years before Apple
came out
with the iPod I was supposed to do a
book about you know the digital media
revolution like 25 years ago and instead
of writing the book I saw that people
would be running around with little
digital devices filled with civilization
they'd be in your pocket one thing which
came after another and I decided to
create a company instead of write about
me
audible groups so fast that by 2008
Amazon paid a reported 300 million
dollars to buy it how much did Amazon
change the equation the beautiful thing
is that we have a currently really
independent culture brand and business
model there very much support what we're
doing a newer do they you know
necessarily agree with everything we're
doing I don't really know all I know is
that we've had an amazing run here the
company moved from neighboring Elizabeth
New Jersey to Newark in 2007 just as new
blood swept into City Hall clear to me
that they've been a good part of it part
of they have great intentions and doing
what they can do mayor Ross Parata is
the latest reformer pushing big ideas
including a goal of having Newark based
corporations like audible Prudential and
Panasonic to hire 2,000 local residents
by next year we can make sure they train
and work with new residents meet them
make sure they help us into schools that
get kids prepared the promise of better
days is helping to erode the stigma
associated with Newark's past the 1969
uprising exposed police brutality and
job inequality and also drove thousands
of residents out draining the city of
its once-mighty tax base and political
accountability those days are gone but
as some degree of prosperity returns
Baraka hopes to ensure his city's
comeback won't leave those who've always
lived here behind the economy grows in
the city it's our job as leaders and
electives here in the town to make sure
that wealth that comes in the community
is redistributed in such a way that the
majority of residents can see some
benefit from it would you ever have
thought this was your future Newark New
Jersey no no I thought that I was going
to move to California
and do something to cool out there a
Jana post is one example she found a job
at audible one year ago after struggling
through a tough adolescence I was living
in a homeless shelter here in Newark
called coven house yes and they have a
program here at audible called hire
local she will enroll in college next
year thanks to another audible program
that pays for the majority of tuition
for all employees it's changed her
trajectory all because the people who
create cutting-edge audio have also
learned to listen to the needs of those
around them they helped me shape my
future now by investing their training
their hiring for their programs
everything they've done has helped me
achieve what I am today we basically
said as long as you're bright and
gregarious we'll take it from there
have you been able to filter up that
talent pool in the high ranks of the
company our representative I'm more
interested in the organic impact you're
creating jobs at all levels for all
kinds of people
this Cathedral is filled with people
have come from all over the world or at
the top of their game in technology this
and as audible continues to change the
way we enjoy books it's helped open up a
brand new chapter for the City of Newark
look everyone in America loves a
comeback story it's one of a great kind
of you know storytelling kind of tropes
and being part of it actually has a real
lot of meaning and uplifting character
and and you know I I would say the fact
that so many people want to work here is
justification enough to continue to try
to help the city after the break we take
you to a hospital in Haiti that's become
a leading beacon for hope
the devastating earthquake that struck
Haiti in 2010 killed an estimated
250,000 people it became the deadliest
natural disaster in the history of the
Western Hemisphere billions of dollars
poured in to help
despite that little has changed but as
we discovered on our visit back to Haiti
earlier this year there is one bright
spot that could provide a path for the
future our trip began in the capital
port-au-prince in the wake of Haiti's
worst year since the earthquake mass
protests gang violence rampant political
corruption jobs are scarce but perhaps
most tragically basic medical care can
be almost impossible to find so this is
the general hospital in port-au-prince
or at least it should be the hospital
after the earthquake decimated the old
hospital a new one was planned
immediately after more than 80 million
has been spent on it it sits empty today
in the meantime the old General Hospital
what should be the main source of care
for Haiti's biggest city reeks of raw
sewage piles of trash are everywhere
that noise on the air and her four month
old son have been here for eight days
[Music]
he has to go and he can't go to the
bathroom
sorry I can't imagine the pain that he's
in right now many patients don't get
treated because they're often required
to provide the medical supplies
something as simple as surgical gloves
that the hospital can't afford but take
a trip outside the capital and you find
a remarkable place that many doubted
could ever exist in this country this is
st. Boniface Hospital in Fond du Blanc
up the mountains on Haiti's southern
peninsula it was started in 1983 and in
the last 10 years has become a leading
beacon for Haitian hope people come from
hours away to this hospital and it could
be anything the emergency room maternity
anything Conor Shapiro is the president
of health equity International which
oversees Saint Boniface he first came
here in 2003 and his wife is Haitian on
the day the earthquake struck he was at
work massive shaking all the patients
came running out of the hospital all the
staff everyone was running into the yard
we didn't know what had happened my wife
was pregnant with our now nine-year-old
was in port-au-prince at the time and I
didn't know what was going on I can only
imagine what that was like I was very
fortunate my wife and our daughter they
survived and many people were not as
fortunate it was a horrible situation
instead of falling apart
Boniface has only grown they now get
five hundred patients a day and went
from an annual operating budget of two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars when
Shapiro took over to eight million today
people risk their lives to get here
because they have no other choice this
is the entrance road to the hospital it
is full of ruts it is mountainous
passable only by dirt bikes like this
and 4x4 vehicles these bikes effectively
act
as ambulances for people who need care
the drive up that treacherous road takes
the better part of an hour that's in
addition to the three or four hours it
can take just to get to the entrance
this woman is nine months pregnant and
could deliver at any moment
okay we have patients coming all day
it's a constant flow of patients for
more than two million people on the
southern peninsula this is the only
place to get an emergency c-section the
only place with a neonatal intensive
care unit we have 35 babies here over
95% of these babies were born here at
the hospital in the maternity center if
this unit weren't here what would happen
to these kids and what percent of them
who are here survive right now we've
been able to make it so that 85% of the
babies here surviving st. boniface has
become one of the primary teaching
hospitals in all of Haiti
it houses the spinal cord trauma center
that treated many of the people injured
in the earthquake I think what's great
is we're not treating most of those
spinal cord injured patients who came
from the earthquake and the reason is
they're back home living their lives
they've learned how to become productive
members of society despite their
handicap we've been able to reach our
goal of reintegrating them and allowing
them to go back to being full productive
members of society
that could not be more true for Mac Sony
persona every morning he wheels himself
up the hill to work at st. Boniface
helping people just as they helped him
her Sona was trapped under rubble for
three days after the earthquake when he
was pulled out he was told he would
never walk again where would you be if
it weren't for this place maybe didn't
allow e course at the medication equal
to maybe I don't know maybe I'd be in
the street maybe I'd find someplace to
live I don't know where I'd be very
likely might not be alive we exactly
Monica Lee st. Boniface does not turn
any patients away they also received no
money from the Haitian government they
survive in a mix of private donations
and outside grants doctor inna Bayer
Pierre is in charge of running the
hospital on a daily basis he's been at
Saint Boniface for 18 years I think we
inspire people and that's why also
teaching has been more and more part of
what we do here because we want to
inspire a new model in the Haitian
healthcare system and with not tons of
finances their way is to improve
healthcare system with some commitment
accountability and hard work we asked
Connor Shapiro why Boniface has
succeeded when so many others have
failed there's no magic potion here it's
just been this slow successful bill that
that has been given time yes absolutely
the community here has been the leader
of this project from the beginning they
are the ones now working here at the
hospital really it's about investing in
the Haitian people in the physicians the
health practitioners the nurses lab
techs who are here already and then we
need to invest in them to be able to
provide that care there are lots of
excuses for why things can go wrong in
Haiti we just don't accept any of them
because we know that this is the right
thing to do you can find more stories
like this
every week on CBS this morning it's
Saturday and join us for live news
coverage 24/7 right here on CBS n
available for free across all platforms
thanks for watching